a henderson man sentenced today for  killing his second wife allen still  wester faces 15 to 45 years in prison  this case dates back to 2011  when his first wife was found dead and  at the time he was questioned but not  charged eight years later his second  wife karen byer was also found dead  under similar circumstances  investigators later ruled that death a  homicide and sylvester was arrested for  murder today by her sister spoke in  court  she's deeply mourned and profoundly  missed  karen was not lost to us  she did not pass away  karen was taken from us with unspeakable  violence  and evil  intent she went on to say sylwester's  smooth deceptions only magnified their  family's suffering  he is also facing charges in california  for his first wife's death